I would really like it if you joined our
reddit discussion forum it this has
grown it started with a couple of
hundred hardcore david pakman show fans
who would post on our reddit discussion
forum at david pakman.com slash reddit
re d di t and it has swelled now to over
1,500 over 1500 people from our audience
which is still a very small portion of
the audience is involved in the
discussion forum interview ideas are
presented all the time their questions
about the show criticisms about the show
which I'm absolutely fine with and we
don't censor or remove in any way it's a
really great place for viewers and
listeners to talk to each other I'm on
their daily Pat now is on there he's
mixing it up on the david pakman show
read it so let's go through just a few
of the different questions and
discussions that have popped up that i
found interesting over the last week
really good question about fair use we
had uh a user jay 473 who said hey when
you play clips from CNN or wherever else
you have to get permission from CNN are
you permitted by law what's the deal
with that and I I sort of explain that
fair use is something people often hear
about fair use is something that would
only be proven in the event of a
copyright dispute I believe that we are
using clips from CNN etcetera as part of
an analysis and therefore it would be
allowed under fair use but you don't
just use it under fair use as a
copyright attorney explained to his fair
use would be your defense if there was
ever a dispute and we've learned over
time you don't play anything from the
NFL they are very litigious and
aggressive with copyright claims you
don't play anything from local news
station so like Fox News no problem
playing stuff from Fox News Fox 5 Dallas
Texas for example I don't even know if
that exists do not go near that because
within seconds in many cases you will
have a copyright claim against you so
that's the deal as far as that goes
another interesting discussion from our
reddit discussion forum Pakman have you
been watching westworld if not why not
I've heard that West world is absolutely
fan
tastic I don't have HBO so I haven't
been able to get access to it and uh
I'll leave it there I know there will be
suggestions about illegal ways to obtain
the show but of course I would never do
that also we have been talking about
what the names for the upcoming David
show david pakman show coffee blends
should be we're going to have a custom
espresso bean roast and a custom drip
coffee bean roast and we've had a lot of
different suggestions there one that I'm
showing you here is related to a comment
Louis once made if i accidentally brewed
some coffee I'd probably drink the
coffee it's funny but not everybody will
understand that reference Louis of
course famously saying once if I
accidentally had a kid I'd probably love
the kid and that became the stuff of
legend of from former producer louis MO
tommy i like it just a little too inside
baseball i think pat yeah that's a
little bit too much of an inside joke
but there are definitely suggestions i
like like progresso for one of them yeah
except that's a soup brand I didn't I
yeah I guess it is progresso soup and
that's it seems a little weird to use
that but there are some really good
suggestions and we're going to have some
of them on monday please keep sending
them in and and the the best ones will
make it onto the show monday and then
lastly here's a suggestion from our
reddit discussion forum should david
pakman cover more local politics i
assume david pakman works near boston so
I'm sure there are races there that
could be covered in it would be
interesting if he did I'm going to go
through my local ballot on tomorrow's
show here in Massachusetts but
ninety-nine point nine percent of our
audience is not voting in the same place
that I'm voting certainly not Boston and
most of the audience not in
Massachusetts so I don't know Pat how
much it would be interesting to the
audience for me to talk about the
sheriff's race here in Suffolk County
for example but sometimes races here
have national implications like a Senate
races and I'm sure we'll be covering the
2018 Elizabeth Warren rerun too if Curt
Schilling former baseball player runs
against Elizabeth Warren believe me
we're going to be covering that that
that would be one of 100 senators in the
US Senate so please join our reddit
discussion forum david pakman.com slash
our EDD
EIT a lot happening there